Alors il a dit que tu es le pouvoir
Défiez toute comparaison et montrez que
C'est comme si j'y allais seul alors c'est comme
Si quelqu'un y va seul, même un peu,
J'ai l'impression qu'il y a quelque chose ici
[musique]
Shri Ram, c'était comme s'il y avait de l'alcool ici.
Si c'est vrai, alors cela aussi au même endroit où il
Avec le recul, elle s'est également transformée en pierre et elle
la pierre est toujours là
Est arrivé
à Ajay
Le projet qui les rejoint depuis le
Usine de déchets de Baad Tu Suno Infections Khat
Les Dalits népalais seront systématiquement
est requis dans le système
Butin de la scène Jai Hind Vidyalaya Chauraha
Service de sélection Vidyapeeth Inter Buddhi Ko
Todi recherche un cri d'argent vert ciel
Il devrait y avoir un voyage, il devrait y avoir un voyage, cher Rajasthan.
frappé au Rajasthan
fais-le
vous bénéficiez de l'aide sociale
Il n'y a pas grand chose dans ce livre
Ce qui fut décidé en rentrant à Somnath
Si vous l'avez pris ici en partant, vous l'avez pris ici.
J'ai dû voir que bientôt il deviendra célèbre
J'aurais aimé pouvoir vous rencontrer ici plus tôt.
Est-ce un morceau de pierre ou pas ?
Quand Prajapat vivait, ces ustensiles étaient trouvés ainsi.
Sont
[musique]
Que mes amis vont certainement me manger des éléments.
C'est vrai qu'on avait de l'alcool ici.
Monsieur, c'est il y a le Nouvel An, vous étiez une ville.
Il y avait un saint et il s'est souvenu de prendre du lait.
Il a dit à ses méchants disciples que vous
Allez-y pleinement et moi sur 12 ans de pénitence
Je suis assis et tu es assis là dans toute la ville
Go And Sunshine Panchkadi L'arrière est ouvert Scud
Il y a un missile et il y a aussi l'ordre du roi.
Tyagi n'envoie de pousse-pousse Panchgani à personne.
étalé trois couches, il est devenu très en colère
Sage, il était très en colère
Lut a dit quel que soit ton amant
Alors je vais t'avoir Panchgani enfant.
Il y aura une rivière quelque part si tu pars d'ici
juste avant le coucher du soleil
Que le sage, pendant que le soleil dormait objectivement,
commandé entendu tout entendre cerf-volant avec tous les boutons
Quand je l'ai donné, il a fait un grand bruit.
Et les gens là-bas, etc. qui sont derrière toutes les pierres
c'est devenu vrai
[Appréciation]
Angry Birds le rend bruyant pour la première fois
100 défauts mylife Intel Science Monitor
Qu'y a-t-il exactement en quantité ?
S'il y a un fantôme, alors Vivek Investigation
Je garde toujours l'esprit ouvert lorsqu'il s'agit de
Abonnez-vous à quelque chose sur rendez-vous
N'oubliez pas de le faire car venez sur cette chaîne
à Ajay
La luxation des notes de suicide est totalement vieillie
Différents types de caméras Une seule caméra visuelle
Déesse Shiva à minuit, caméra principale
Caméras de sécurité pour les huiles usées dans les stands
Installer la caméra de vision nocturne à partir de la caméra Trail
Le stand où nous le mangeons est
Le temple le plus célèbre du temple Kiradu est Someshwar.
On dit de la campagne du temple que
Cet endroit est d'un côté si quelqu'un la nuit
et s'arrête ou après le coucher du soleil
Même si vous l’arrêtez, il se transformera en pierre.
Le magasin commence à cet endroit, c'est-à-dire un
Comment le temps peut dire que toute cette focalisation
Le centre d'attraction est celui-ci
Une chose que je vais faire maintenant, c'est que je
J'entrerai seul dans le temple et là
Je vais tuer le temps, la vie reviendra
Je vais examiner votre point pour en savoir plus
Je dois essayer ce qui m'arrive à l'intérieur
Nous devenons différents de l’extérieur et de l’intérieur.
Je resterai en contact si quelque chose se passe là-bas
Oui mais il faut faire une entrée sinon
Je me transforme vraiment en pierre Song Ye
tout se passera devant toi
Est-il possible d'observer le jeûne uniquement dans le temple de Krishna ?
même après avoir été seul
que j'appartiens à mon mari
qu'un
Ma photo
Est arrivé
je suis en route pour
que ceci suit cela
fais-le
Être cette passion
Est-ce que ce dessin est par exemple Honey Singh jusqu'à ce que
C'est un autre Vellore riche ici
Qui du jour local à ça si ça et ça
que t'arrive-t-il si tu es seul
Celui qui est là, viens au fort
[musique]
Kapil Sibal m'a dit
manteau sur
fais-le
Précédent Song Phir Couple de scientifiques Après
Times You For Your Kind Act Navneet
Sequeira 55ème 6ème Temple
Arrivée de l'écran gauche pour cela
Cela se passe à l'intérieur en ce moment
Qu'il y a des soleils qui nous donnent un
Disons-le directement pour rester à cet endroit ici
Mais nous sommes avec Som, nous continuerons à soutenir
et voyons le potentiel
Est arrivé
[musique]
bonjour les téléspectateurs corrigé
à l'Assemblée de New Delhi
avoir du Bluetooth
À quelle usine ressemble-t-il ?
à Ajay
fais-le
[musique]
qu'un
que si vous regardez partout dans le monde, il y en a beaucoup
Nous allons maintenant vous indiquer l’état des rougeurs.
J'ai dû l'écrire dans ma tête comment c'est ici
J'essaie de faire tomber le haut-parleur.
Ou cinq jours plus tard, la température a soudainement augmenté
exprimer une chose à construire dans un tel endroit
sans un c'est très beau
Si ce tilak est constitué de grosses pierres, il sera pillé en premier.
Et il fait très ensoleillé toute la journée
S'il habite ici, c'est une question de son côté.
La température proviendra de ce temple particulier.
il y aura plus
qu'un
à Ajay
[musique]
200 raisons derrière la distorsion du sable de papa
La séquence vidéo en gros Joe Scalp
trop avec la radiofréquence
Les festivals effectifs sont complètement fermés et
Si vous êtes assis à proximité, alors il y a de l'adversité.
La fréquence radio peut avoir augmenté en raison de
Cela arrivera, non ?
399 402
Bonne fortune assignée à la mise en œuvre de la médecine technologique
Mais l'électro-aimant depuis les observances
directeurs de radiofréquences donc
Friends Sonic Booster pour le son
fréquences de
J'ai des problèmes informatiques à mon travail.
Quand il vient, vous étiez déjà attiré par lui.
Photo des personnes et de la culture du lieu
La mère donne une contribution gratuite et aussi
En espérant que si nous y allons, nous obtiendrons ce que
Il ne sera vu qu'avec la portion lorsqu'il
Si vous entrez, je le serai probablement aussi plusieurs fois
faire face à la mortalité, penser à beaucoup de choses
Cela pourrait faire la différence derrière York
la société de bourse est individuelle
Est arrivé
C'est un monde de chiens Zuber Ali notre société
des milliers de personnes marchent chaque jour
Superstitions, Tantra-Mantras, etc.
Des milliers de personnes au nom de la magie noire
sont tués et les femmes s'enfuient
Les tarifs sont effectués avec de tels lots
Toutes les pratiques entrent dans ce giron dans notre société.
Cela se produit au nom de tout être humain
Il n'y a pas d'abri de ce type à proximité qui puisse être utilisé
J'ai demandé que je puisse arranger ta vie
Je peux résoudre les problèmes de ta vie
Je vais résoudre vos problèmes moi-même
Flex a également été très honnête mais SIM
Fente laver le visage pour que la semoule soit légèrement
vivre dans le monde
ce rl dans le noir
fais-le